we're gonna get a 3 000 rated player for
the last game of the day
called us from poland whom i apparently
haven't played before
and i'm going to go for a somewhat or
a very proactive opening here no that
was the most slip i was intending d6
okay i'll try and make the best of it
develop the bishop
pretend like nothing's wrong
this isn't very promising though if i
can get d6 and then e5
yeah de6 is probably a decent move
because
knight d4 here for instance and it seems
like he's just gonna be somewhat better
with a better pawn structure now
this i'm less worried about
seeing as now i do have
fairly fairly good development
i think i should save that bishop we
don't give away
measure pairs here
for free or when we do we at least
try and pretend that we have a good
reason
to to do that in general my position
looks
completely sound now
yeah my opponent has not
has not gone out of his way to try and
punish me here
and this i think drops upon
it's always a bit
you know it's always a bit uh
suspect to grab these pawns in the
middle of the center
um in the middle of the center that
sounds like nonsense in the center
when you haven't castle but i don't
think
you can punch it uh
yeah let's go knight g5
takes it let's
protect
it doesn't come some compensation here
yeah at this moment i didn't see did not
see at all
i thought it would go knight c4 there
though
now i should be able to consolidate with
uh
with a consider considerable edge
the thing is here i don't really want a
castle
i probably should though
because i i really rather want to go g6
to control some
um to control some um to go
to control some light squares and then
king f8 and then king g7
um the problem is g6 maybe c4 and then
c5
b6 then b4 maybe i don't actually have
time for that
the reason i didn't like castles is now
he could have uh gone e4
and taking control over some light
squares and
it would have been slightly inconvenient
for me since i obviously cannot play g6
because of
bishop takes g6 now i will go
king g7 um f5
e4 later on there are no weaknesses in
my position
uh and uh eventually
my majority
or on on the king side um
with that extra pawn eventually i think
that is going to tell
i have to be a bit careful now uh f5
then b4 and i'm probably setting myself
up
for for some trouble um so
yeah just a little bit careful but now
now i'm doing great
um bishop e2 e3 and
his king is going to be going to be weak
for the
for the rest of the game
uh there are no tactics like rookie one
f5 or b4 queen e4 rook takes d6 queen
takes c6 followed by rook t1 winning a
rook
but now the ice queen is out of play
once again no weaknesses in my position
and um queen f4
um looks very uh very enticing next
okay um this is uh
this is the best try obviously let's
just make a random move
um in order to pass the move to him
and or you could actually have taken
that was oh
i had bishop h2 what am i thinking
what i had bishop h2 uh bishop h2 would
have won on the spot
winning the queen that's really really
bad really really bad
okay now anyway we if he takes both
rooks i got queen c7 check
bring the rook back meaning that i have
um
i have a queen against the bishop i have
18 seconds but that's
more than enough okay he fights
he fights on well though let's see one
take on a3
queen b2 a3 run run run
a1 another
lady appearing very soon
and this game is not not going to last
very long
take it
and checkmate that was about premium
actually
c5 this would not have been checkmate
uh i was getting a little bit you're
there without with the time
anyway that's it for
today